my resting times were times i wasn't  working by default and i never spent a  lot of time thinking about rest but this  year i watched a few of my close friends  and colleagues go through burnout i  realized that if i wasn't more  intentional with my rest  my schedule wasn't gonna magically open  up for me to rest by scheduling my  breaks directly into my calendar as a  non-negotiable activity i know it sounds  really simple but it really helped me to  re-strategize on my work and schedule  things around it  and it also forced me to think about the  activities that would actually help me  recharge my batteries and um help me  optimize my rest sometimes that's going  for a hike and sometimes that's watching  the office for the 50th time